estas imágenes de circuito cerrado de
televisión en la base aérea de engels en
Rusia captan un sonido que ensordece
seguido de un brillante Destello de luz
Moscú acusó a Ucrania de estar detrás de
los ataques contra dos bases aéreas
incluida engels vista en estas imágenes
de satélite un día antes el Ministerio
de defensa ruso lo calificó de acto
terrorista destinado a perturbar su
aviación de largo alcance en lo que
sería el ataque más importante de
Ucrania en territorio ruso desde el
inicio de la guerra se dice que esta
imagen de satélite muestra los daños en
la base aérea de diagoleo en riazán
Rusia dice haber derribado los drones
ucranianos los restos causan bajas rusas
en tierra
a causa de la caída y explosión de los
restos en los aeródromos rusos por
aviones no tripulados el revestimiento
del fuselaje de dos aviones resultó
ligeramente dañado tres técnicos
militares rusos que se encontraban en el
aeródromo murieron
la base aérea de engels en la región
rusa de saratov estaba a más de 600
kilómetros al este de la frontera con
Ucrania y alberga bombarderos con
capacidad nuclear el martes el
gobernador de kursk cerca de la frontera
ucraniana también informó de un ataque
con drones a un aeródromo de la región y
dijo que se había incendiado un camión
cisterna de almacenamiento de petróleo
de confirmarse la autoría no sería la
primera vez que kiev ataca territorio
ruso explosiones anteriores dañaron
almacenes de armas y depósitos de
combustible en regiones rusas cercanas a
Ucrania
no ha reivindicado directamente la
autoría de ninguna de las expresiones y
el asesor del presidente ucraniano se
mostró Igualmente críptico el lunes si
se lanza algo el espacio aéreo de otros
países tarde o temprano los objetos
voladores desconocidos volverán a su
Punto de partida también sin reivindicar
la autoría en Twitter la fuerza aérea
ucraniana comentó airadamente que ha
pasado junto a fotos de lo que parecen
aviones dañados en ria